this is the new SFMOMA for three years
it's been closing the public
undergoing a major expansion the
renovated museum is among the most
considered gallery spaces in the world
not to mention America's largest
repository of modern art the redesign
nearly tripled its prior gallery space
and that means there is a lot more to
see and yes that's exciting but it can
also be a little overwhelming to help
guide you through the museum SFMOMA
teamed up with Apple and a company
called D door to develop an app that
totally reimagines the audiosurf
experience to get started just to let
the tour you want press play and slip
your phone in your pocket
look up at the white mobile tentacles
hovering silently above this spacious
entry hall DCF take a walk beneath them
see how it changes
that's angry truffle Minj in the podcast
99% invisible she's just one of the
people you'll hear from on the new audio
tubes
here's another favorite it's Philippe
Petit the French tightrope walker now go
left and we'll pull the weights within
next gathering mix things up the museum
recorded colorful commentary from
podcasters comedians sports casters and
artists you will see Picasso's and
Mathieu system or the early modern
artists but don't move yourself to these
keep going straight ahead okay coming to
this corner gallery and see whether any
of the works in here invite you to stop
and think
for half a century audio tour is
required punching numbers in the keypads
but SFMOMA zap is nothing like the
museum's immersive tours flow
uninterrupted from piece to piece
gallery to gallery one room to the next
I'll let you know where to go as we book
no need to keep looking at your screen
go slowly like me I do something with
dickerers I once from Museum the app
uses the museum's Wi-Fi keep tabs on
where you are and guide you through each
space you really got to experience it
for yourself but it feels really magical
these immersive audio tours aren't
perfect stray from the path the
voice-over fades out and you get some
nice elevator music instead the app can
tell you where to go to resume the tour
but if you wander too far astray it can
have some trouble getting you back on
track plus sometimes the beauty of the
gallery experience is just wandering
around getting a little lost and
stumbling upon that one piece that
totally captivates you the ideal audio
tour is one that adapts to spontaneity
and doesn't prescribe a predetermined
path that is a pretty big ask but it's
one that SFMOMA is actively working for
in the meantime this app is a giant step
in the right direction
you